what other uh strategies have you been
able to leverage um to
minimize your tax burden because that's
usually one of the most
uh expensive uh lines on my quickbooks
that i've noticed in the past i mean
what else have you seen that's uh
a little tip or a trick you know if you
got anything for us tom or robert or ken
well the first thing to understand is is
really what the tax law is all about
that you know most of the tax law is
really a bunch of incentives and the
government wants you to put your money
in certain places and the key is to find
those incentives so real estate is one
of those incentives uh need to build
housing you'll need to build commercial
properties so we have real estate tax
incentives there are others energy
um clean energy especially is a big one
renewable energy
there are tax credits there's there's
tax deductions for for clean energy
there's um
you know other energy oil and gas um in
the u.s there's big deductions for oil
and gas technology business agriculture
i mean there are really a lot of
incentives
99 of the tax law in all of our
countries is uh just a series of
incentives it's just instruction guide
basically to reducing your taxes so all
all the government's saying is look we
need certain things done
and if you do those things then we're
going to encourage that by giving you a
tax break and uh because because we want
you to do it rather than have us do it
and then we'll share the profits when
the profits come
are there
states that are more business friendly
than other states
oh yeah sure
yeah yeah
yeah well we're starting to see rent
control pop up we're starting to see
rent caps pop up there are some that
actually have passed
so you know capital markets you were
talking about you know the big money
institutional
it's gonna go you know it's going to go
to where it's a little a little more
friendly and
i think that's what's happening now
right people are voting with their feet
and their checkbooks
based on those things happening right
now we're seeing it real time that's
wonderful um robert i want to ask you
this question how do you select your tax
guy because i always struggle to find
great tax planners most of them will
like to prefer to color within the lines
every dot must be you know perfect every
team must be crossed there is no you
know room for gray area i like a guy
that's you know more willing to lean
into to asking for
for forgiveness than asking for
permission so i'm curious about how you
chose a guy like tom you know for
example
well as that old at all saying goes you
kiss a lot of frogs to find the fairy
princess
i had i had a lot of bad ones and threw
a bad one i bet tom
but tom wrote this book called tax free
wealth it's a it's a it's a book for
entrepreneurs because we're not the
brightest guys on earth
and you can read the book and the most
important thing after being tax-free
well you'll know what questions to ask
and it'll save you a lot of time and uh
and tom is definitely within the lines
because we wouldn't cross him it's not
worth it
is it would you say that's true tom yeah
and let me add to that rich so
really the question is is how much does
your tax advisor know about the tax law
it's it you really don't want them to go
outside their knowledge so if you've got
somebody who's you know pushing the
envelope it's probably because they
don't knowing they don't know the entire
tax law and so the more they more you
understand about the tax law the more
you really understand that wow you know
what this tax law is actually built
to reduce your taxes if you do what the
government wants done so it's really a
matter of understanding the tax law as
opposed to having to push the limits of
the tax law right
and again the question the thing for
every entrepreneur is what questions to
ask
those are very important questions how
do you how do you decide that
why tom's book is called tax free wealth
read the book there you go tax free
wealth where is it on amazon it's
everywhere
and is it that specific to the united
states or a certain region or a certain
state or it's not it's very it's it's
very much about the concepts of tax law
so we have i mean i've had people
talk to me in romania and and great
britain and canada and mexico it doesn't
matter because the concepts right we're
we're not looking the specifics is what
you have a tax advisor for but you you
need to understand what you can do
uh to reduce your taxes you know one of
the things that um we look at is
uh you think about a conservative versus
an aggressive um tax
advisor and really a conservative tax
advisor just somebody that um
does
things within what they know so anytime
you have somebody who doesn't know very
much then they're going to be very
aggressive what i always tell people
though to robert's point about asking
questions is the advisor's primary job
is not to give answers the advisor's
primary job is to ask the right
questions so the best way to know if
your tax advisor is a good tax advisor
is are they asking you good questions
and that's pretty easy you can tell that
you've got a pretty good idea oh yeah
they're thinking about this they're
asking me this they're looking at kind
of a holistic approach to taxes and
they're not just saying no you can do
this and you can't do that
how do you spot a bad tax advisor
oh my heavens well that's about 90 plus
percent of them unfortunately yeah
they're people
so
you know we're all entrepreneurs right
so i always say no entrepreneur wants to
be told what they can't do they don't
only want to be told how to do what they
want to do
so to me a good tax advisor attorney
financial planner whoever it is is
somebody that's going to help you get
where you want to go and that's really
that it's really that thought process
it's how you think about it that makes
the big difference and what questions
that um then the tax advisor asks you to
get where you want to go got it
so rich if i'm at one more thing the
reason i want it's always ken and tom
because
in the world of money it's always debt
and taxes
so kenny provides the debt he has three
books first book is abc's it's the basic
of real estate investing
then then he has one for property
management which is key you've got to
have a good property manager that's the
hardest thing about real estate
and the third is the advanced guide
so if you go through ken's book and
books three books and tom's books
then you'll be better able to find a
better tax advisor because
i think kenny's book the piece the
resistance is at last book is the
advanced guide
it's how we make millions of dollars and
pay no taxes legally
when you read that then you start
hunting down a guy like tom wheelwright
as fast as you can
and the other last thing i want to say
because with this question here we the
three of us have traveled the world
again we have a great time
kenny was locked up in moscow as usual
but anyway
the rich the tax laws are fundamentally
the same all over the world because tom
flies let's say we fly into romania
tom will check it out he says it's
exactly the same
and everybody says well our tax laws are
different here
but no matter which country we've been
to and you know kenny and tom have done
a lot of work in canada
the laws are the same
when you say the laws are the same um
like just to sort of expand on that like
we're we're dealing with
like
uh
cuisine in countries varies but you
still have you know pretty much the same
ingredients right is what we're dealing
with
yeah so here's what i would say rich
you know the the financial system in the
u.s the financial system in canada are
very different but one thing that's
the same
is the banks are trying to get
everybody's money in savings and the
wealth managers are trying to get
everybody's money to manage it
so what if you understand that then you
understand how to get that money
because that old money all that money
funnels into all those things
so when i go out to get money
in the form of debt
i actually get it you know through banks
through pension funds through insurance
no different in canada i mean all that
money is managed and then those money
managers look for guys like me to place
it
that is absolutely the same
so it really all
is opm or other people's people
and that's one thing that's for sure and
what the banks are trying to do of
course if i let's say i get a million
bucks from you and it's in in savings
and i'm paying you one percent i'm
trying to lend it back to me at say five
and you know so that's that's how it
works is they're taking your money and
basically letting it to me and but the
collateral is a project that i find
that's the system that we're in it's the
same across the entire world yeah and
rich even from a tax standpoint i mean
the incentives are the same your
government wants the same things mike
our government wants you know they want
housing they want energy they want ag
you know food
they want they want business they want
technology
the incentives don't change
yeah how they apply those incentives are
going to change
you know
from time to time um the very specific
details of that you do have to have a
local tax advisor but the but the
overall view of the government what the
government wants to do in the government
incentives are absolutely remarkably the
same you know we have here what's called
a 401k which is a retirement plan like
your rrsp um
in
in japan they actually have something
they call a 401k
so
they've actually copied us exactly and
so the you know you take those
retirement plans yeah there's a little
difference for example rrsp you have a
lot more flexibility in taking that out
than we do uh superannuation in
australia they have even more um
flexibility than you do but they're
still the same idea there's still the
idea of putting money into a retirement
plan getting a tax break and then taking
it out when you retire so it's still the
same incentive it's still the same idea
gotcha
you